era in the mid fours
nice strikeout to walk ratio solid
opponents batting average
the one thing he's been a little bit
prone to early in the season in five
starts is the home run ball he's given
up eight home runs
which has accounted for a lot of the
runs that he's given up obviously
and verdugo pops this one up
short right field or right center
however you want to look at it gallow
gets to it
and it's two up two down one two pitch
swinging a miss he struck him out
he curved him there and it's a one two
three top of the first for michael gary
fulton
garrett richards will pitch for the red
sox what he did in his last start
that was against the met seven innings
one run no walks and ten strikeouts
well his first pitch is lined into
center field a base hit
for calhoun and so willie wastes no time
extending his hitting streak now career
best
nine for calhoun one two again to solac
look to hold up they did appeal and
that's a swing and a miss he got him he
struck him out
doesn't go solo as that curveball we
were talking about dave you know a good
one right out of the shoot here for
garrett richards wild pitch puts calhoun
at third and low
at second base and 1-2 to gallow
and struck him out 81 miles an hour and
got him to go
big strikeout for garrett richards
curveball again
0-2 swing and a miss he got him down and
in it was a 90-mile an hour change up
and that retires the side
here's the one two zander swings and
pops it up
on the infield right near second base
shortstop and second baseman converts in
its front
it falls solid lost it
in the sun he just completely lost right
here he has
no idea where that ball is i can't see
it i can't see it
lying the other way into the alley
garcia over to cut it
and rounding it on his way to third
zander bogarts and into second base
standing up marwin gonzales so the red
sox are in business
that's the kind of hitting alex cora
wants to see use that opposite field
second and third with one out this is
where you need contact from hunter
renfro
ground ball hit toward the middle to get
a run home second baseman solak has it
flips to first for the out bogart scores
over to third scoots gonzalez
one-nothing red sox
and here's the pitch and a bouncing ball
over the mound but
gloved by connor falefa right on the bag
at second he fires the first to
end the inning red sox with a tainted
run
on two hits and one left and after an
inning and a half it's one nothing red
sox
three two pitch coming here it is and he
got him a swing and missed it
inside fastball that a good movement
strike three
we've got four strikeouts
ground ball top first base side grabbed
by the shortstop bogart's on the left
side he throws out his buddy eric comes
back with a one two three inning after
two
the number nine hitter in the lineup
today for the red sox
the one two and a swing and a miss
plawecki
is the second strikeout victim this
afternoon for fulton evac all right
top of the order coming up and a 1-1
coming
the other way nicely done pass brock
hold for base hit
so the red sox have a couple of men on
yeah usually we see uh
we see verdugo go the opposite field
against left-handed pitches this time he
doesn't get
fulton evans the right-hander as
martinez hits a one-hopper to short
kinder philip at a second for one so
lacked the first double play
fulton should dispenses with the drama
and gets the 6-4-3
double play
ball into right field base hit for
calhoun who's now two for two
another big hit for willie calhoun tk
hernandez was out there in shallow right
but that one was hit between
bogarts and hernandez bogart's playing a
straight up second base position
caught on and missed he got him again he
strikes him out for the second time and
that's five already for richards yeah
not quite sure what that pitch was a cut
fastball or a slider
2-2 strike three called on the outside
corner brian o'norah has been consistent
low watches strike three and garrett
richards has six punch-outs
through three bogarts hit the pop-up
that was lost in the sun in the second
it went down as a hit
high fly ball left center field he
jacked it deep back it goes it is gone
yes sir xander bogart's with number five
and it's two nothing boston
oh it's sounded gone three infielders to
the right of second again the 3-2 pitch
swinging them in
gonzalez out as a fulton image
looked like went to either the slider or
curve there
to take care of gonzalez just by a few
feet
as cordero swings and pops one up left
side of the infield holt goes from
sunshine to shade
and near the bag he makes a one-hand
test to get cordero for the final out
a run for boston on the home run by
bogarts they leave a runner we've played
three and a half
all right here's dahl with the runner at
third and one out the infield at normal
depth
bouncing ball first base that's a fair
ball and
gallow will score from third on the dog
round down so the rangers get their
first run this afternoon the same way
the red sox did
it's two to one curveball is popped up
into shallow left field will anybody get
it devers out cordero and he's there to
make the play
that was trouble off the bat but by the
hair on his chinny chin chin garrett
richards escapes the fourth with the
lead 2-1 red sox lead after four
and there are runners at the corners for
martinez with one out in the fifth
boston threatening to add to a
two-to-one lead
it hits this one to third base the
second one the relay
got him and another double play around
the horn they go
darwin's in hernandez comes on here in
the sixth inning there's a look at his
numbers on the season
walk totals are a little bit high but
he's throwing the ball
really well recently
that's gonna be in there for strike
three so
low punches out for the second time
they've been living on an outside corner
against left-handed
hitters breaking ball struck him out
looking through him a curve that time
at 76 miles an hour and joey is having
some words
with brian o'nora and joey's been thrown
out of the game
and here comes chris woodward i can't
remember the last time
that a player like joey gallo got tossed
out of the game
and yep there goes woody it's a breaking
ball
that catches the bottom corner of the
plate now if you're a hitter
there's no way that you think this ball
is a strike so two men are out now with
a runner with third top of the order in
[ __ ] hernandez
the other way for a base hit that'll get
it done a run is in
excuse me but i love that
two strikes make contact
avoid the strikeout put the ball and
play
one another verdugo who swings and
drives one here into center field but
white is there
going back a few steps to his right he
hauls in the line drive
for the final out seventh inning stretch
time here at globe life field
garrett whitlock will be the new man on
the mound for boston
yeah the red sox might hit the jackpot
with garrett whitlock he was a rule five
draft pick
as is he drives one deep out into left
field this one's got a shot
and it is out of here home run isaiah
kiner to bring the rangers to within a
run
at 3-2 here's an 0-2 swing and a mess he
struck him out what a bounce back for
whitlock
high fastball solank goes down
on high heat that's big tying run and
scoring position the rangers oh for five
today
with the o2 there's the breaking ball on
the ground runs going to hold at second
bogarts with a dart over to first base
to get him
no chance for low to advance one away
it's gonna be up to david dahl
oh there's a fastball and that one is
through into left field base hit
here comes settle out cordero's throw
goes
i don't know where the run scores
and we're tied at three and the go-ahead
run is in scoring position
holt sends it out to right center fan
that one drops in base hit
the rangers will take the lead dahl is
in they want to add more
counterfeiter will score
the o2 and this one
in the air left field dahl has it and
the rangers
come from behind and win five to three
and win the four game series
three games out of four from boston